you know we know one ellipse is
basically like this oval shape here and
we know the distance from the center to
the vertices we call that distance a the
distance from the center to the co
vertices or the minor version sees this
narrower direction we call that distance
B and the distance from the center to
the full side we call that distance C
now can be more elongated in the Y
direction or in the X direction but the
basic equation is like this X minus H
squared over a squared plus y minus K
squared over B squared is equal to one
so they always equal one you're always
adding but one thing to pay attention to
is that the a and the B can switch and
the main thing is that the a is always
the larger denominator okay so the
larger denominators are a the smaller
one is B and then the eccentricity is
defined as C divided by a meaning the
distance from the center to the full
side divided by the distance from the
center to the vertices and
eccentricities always between 0 and 1
remember the closer gets to 0 the more
that the ellipse looks like a 0 or a
circle and the closer that it gets to 1
the more it looks kind of like the
number 1 it's kind of stretched out and
it's narrow like that and then we have
an equation that ties all these values
together and that's C squared equals a
squared minus B squared and that's the
basic idea so let's see if we can jump
into this problem here if any of this
seems a little bit confusing to you I'll
have links to other videos that I did
talking more about some of the more
beginning level type problems with
graphing ellipses and so on but let's
jump into this problem the first thing I
like to do is just kind of sketch it as
I go along and piece the equation
together also as I go along they're
giving us the full side which are at
positive 2 and then it's at negative 2
plus or minus square root of 3 so what
that means is that from here we're going
up square root of 3 which is about 1.7
okay and down 1.3 which is about 1.7
from from there so the these are your
full sign halfway between your full side
that's the center point so you can see
in this problem the center is at 2 comma
negative 2 and this distance from the
center to the focus is square root of 3
that's our C value okay so you're with
me so far
now the eccentricities equal to square
root 3 over 2 but remember eccentricity
is C divided by a so we have a little
equation here we already figured out
that C is square root of 3
so that means that a must be equal to
two okay so this was kind of an easy one
as far as you know they kind of gave us
a C value we just had to figure out the
a value but basically you just have
square root of 3 over 2 is equal to C
over a this was square root of 3 we're
solving for a you can see that if you
cross multiply or you can just see that
these are equivalent a is equal to 2 now
what that means is that from the center
to the vertex that distance is 2 and
then same thing here down 2 so these are
our vertices right here at 2 0 and 2
negative 4 okay now the foci and the
vertices are always on the longer axis
the major axis so you can see it's going
to be you know stretched more in this
vertical or this Y direction but let's
see if we can piece together what we
have so far so we've got X minus 2
squared plus y plus 2 squared is equal
to 1 okay now the reason I put this this
is the center it's been shifted right to
notice this is the opposite X minus H so
H is positive 2 y minus a negative 2 so
K is negative 2 we're shifting down 2
and the distance again from the center
to the vertex that's a ok now because
I'm going up and down in the vertical
direction that a value is going to be
underneath the Y variable here that's
the Y direction so that's going to be 2
and remember it's 2 squared so this is
actually going to be 4 okay now the only
thing we're left to solve for is B
squared okay this denominator and we're
going to use this equation right here C
squared equals a squared minus B squared
so let's see if we can fill in what we
know here we know that a is 2 so that's
going to be 2 squared is 4 we know C is
square root of 3 but square root of 3
squared is 3 so if we go to solve for B
squared we can see that B squared is
equal to positive 1 so that goes right
here this is 1 of course if we take a
square root of 1 we still get 1 so the
direction in the horizontal direction
okay to the co vertices that distance is
going to be 1 so you can see here we've
got a pretty good sketch of our ellipse
and this is the equation this is what we
were trying to solve for originally and
that wraps it up so again if you want to
learn more about ellipses I'll have
links to other videos I did talking
about some of the more basic and general
ones but subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon